BACK AND WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
TODAY THAT WOULD GIVE IT BACK.
>> Tucker: GIVING ALASKA BACK
TO THE RUSSIANS.
HE LOVES THE RUSSIANS.
YESTERDAY CNN WROTE AN ENTIRE
PIECE PREDICTING THE PRESIDENT
WOULD BE SHOCKED THAT HE CAN’T
EAT STEAK AND BURGERS WHILE IN
INDIA.
SO ABSURD.
NOT ONLY ABSURD, BUT BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY OVER TIME.
CNN HAS DOZENS OF ANCHORS ON
HIGHLY ABATED EXPERTS AND
ANALYSTS AND SMART PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT FOR
THREE YEARS RUNNING.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU A
QUESTION MARK IT TELLS YOU THEY
CANNOT BE TRUSTED WITH POSITIONS
OF PUBLIC TRUST.
AND IN A CRISIS THAT MATTERS.
THESE PEOPLE OUGHT TO RESIGN
TODAY BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY IS
DEGRADING OUR PUBLIC
CONVERSATION.
IT IS MAKING US DUMBER AND
BLINDING US TO WHAT THE REAL
THREATS ARE.
IT IS OBVIOUS TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD BUT NOT OBVIOUS TO US IN
PART BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS SO
STUPID AND SO FAR OFF THAT THEY
CAN’T SEE HOW THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED.
OTHER COLUMNIST MARK STEYN JOINS
US TO ASSESS THE STATE OF ALL OF
THIS.
MARK AS YOU GAZE AROUND THE
GLOBE AT THE EMINENT THREATS
PRESSING IN ON US, WHERE
WOULD YOU RATE RUSSIAN MEMES ON
THAT LIST?
>> I WOULD RATE THEM VERY LOW
ALONG WITH THE THREAT THAT TRUMP
WILL GIVE ALASKA TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE WILL GIVE VERMONT TO
JUSTIN TRUDEAU LONG BEFORE HE
DOES THAT.
AND THAT IS WIN-WIN FOR
EVERYBODY.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT ACTUALLY, I WOULD SLIGHTLY
DISAGREE WITH YOU, TUCKER, THAT
THIS DEMONSTRATES THE TRIVIALITY
OF CNN.
IN ACTUAL FACT, SOMETHING RATHER
PROFOUND IS GOING ON HERE.
AS YOU KNOW, AN OBSESSION WITH
DANGEROUS JOKES USED TO BE A
SIGN OF TOTALITARIAN SOCIETIES.
AND HE WROTE AN EXCELLENT NOVEL
ABOUT IT CALLED "THE JUNK ABOUT
A STUDENT WHOSE ENTIRE LIFE IS
RUINED ABOUT TELLING A JOKE THAT
FAILS TO MEET THE FAVORITE OF
THE COMMUNIST PARTY."
THAT IS ACTUALLY WHAT’S GOING
ON.
IF YOU LISTEN TO ALL OF THAT
TRIPE ABOUT MEMES USING HUMOR TO
ADVANCE PROBLEMATIC IDEAS AND
THE RUSSIANS MUST BE BEHIND
THAT, DO YOU REALIZE WHAT THEY
THINK?
CNN IS ADVANCING THE PROPOSITION
THAT ENJOYING A LAUGH MEANS THAT
YOU ARE BEING MANIPULATED BY THE
KREMLIN.
THIS IS ACTUALLY COMPLETELY
IDIOTIC.
>> Tucker: AND IT IS ALSO
TOTALLY CORROSIVE TO THE
COUNTRY.
I HAVE TO ASK, AND THIS IS NOT A
TOP THE LIST OF IMPORTANT THINGS
BUT I JUST CANNOT CONTAIN
MYSELF.
JOE BIDEN IS CLAIMING ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, ON AT LEAST
THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS THAT HE
WAS ARRESTED IN SOUTH AFRICA
DURING A PARTY.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS DAY, 30 YEARS AGO,
NELSON MANDELA WALKED OUT OF
PRISON AND ENTERED A DISCUSSION
ABOUT APARTHEID APPEARED I HAD
THE GREAT HONOR OF MEETING HIM.
I HAD THE GREAT HONOR OF BEING
ARRESTED WITH A U.N. AMBASSADOR
TRYING TO GET TO SEE HIM IN
ROBBINS ISLAND.
>> I GOT ARRESTED TRYING TO SEE
HIM WHEN I WAS IN SOUTH AFRICA
AND NELSON MANDELA.
>> I CAME BACK FROM SOUTH AFRICA
TRYING TO SEE NELSON MANDELA AND
GOT ROBBED DOMINIC GOT
IMPRISONED.
>> Tucker: IS IT TRUE?
WELL BIDEN’S OWN 2007 WHEN MOORE
NEVER MENTIONS BEING ARRESTED IN
SOUTH AFRICA TRYING TO SEE
NELSON MANDELA.
SOMEONE TRAVELING WITH HIM AT
THE TIME DOES NOT REMEMBER IT
EITHER.
ONE OF CORN POPS LONG LOST
RELATIVE, MARK, WERE YOU THERE
WHEN HE WAS ARRESTED?
TRYING TO BIT NELSON MANDELA?
>> I WAS THERE WHEN BIDEN WAS
ARRESTED TRYING TO SEE MANHATTAN
MCGANN.
HE DID NOT WANT TO SWIM IN THE
POOL WITH THE SECRET SERVICE
AGENTS.
SO JOE LENT HIM A MADE OF HIM
SO.
THESE STORIES ARE QUITE
INTERESTING.
ALL OF THESE FANS WANT TO PLACE
HIM AT THE CENTER OF WORLD
EVENTS.
IT IS LIKE WHEN THEY NEED
AMY KLOBUCHAR WHO RAN INTO
TROUBLE AND FORGET THE NAME OF
THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT BUT
JOE BIDEN IMMEDIATELY SAID TO
COME I’M THE ONLY PERSON ON THIS
WHO WAS THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT.
AND WHOEVER WAS THE MEXICAN
PRESIDENT BEFORE THAT AND THE
GUY THAT WAS THE MEXICAN
PRESIDENT WHO WAS BEFORE THE GUY
WHO WAS THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT
WHO WAS THE GUY BEFORE THE
MEXICAN PRESIDENT.
AND ALL SLIGHTLY PERPLEXING
THINGS AND A RELEVANT MAN WANTS
TO PLACE HIMSELF AT THE CENTER
OF WELL HISTORICAL EVENTS.
AND IN SOME SUBTLE WAY, THESE
PITIFUL FANS OF HIS ACTUALLY
TELL YOU WHY HE IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: WILL, IT IS SO SAD.
HE WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT.
HE WENT TO FOREIGN DICTATORS.